وعد الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي همم
بتزويد اكياس بالمزيد من الاسلحه الكريم
للنتوعد اليوم باحراق الدبابات التي ينوي
الغربيون خصوصا لندن همم ورثوا تسليمها
لكيف للحديث عن هذا الموضوع معي في الاسس
اسامي الوسيم الاحمر اهلا
وسيم بدايه ما الذي دفع همم الغرب
وبريطانيا بشكل خاص الى اتخاذ قرار طبعا
كان هناك خطوه اولى بعد فتره اشهر منذ
بدايه الحرب كان لما يشبه الخط الاحمر لدى
الغربيين الداعمين للكاف لعدم تسليم اسلحه
ثقيله حتى لا تنخرط هذه الدول في صراع
مباشر مع روسيا ما جرى قبل اسبوعين كان
هناك خطوه اولى مع اعلان فرنسا بدايه
المتحده وبريطانيا التزويد مدرعات همم
للدفاعيه لاوكرانيا
وعلى اعتبار ان هناك قراءه انا هذه الحرب
ستكون طويله يجب مساعده اوكرانيا على
المقاومه حتى لا تسقط وانها في حال وصلت
الى مرحله مفاوضات ان تستطيع على الاقل
التفاوض من موقع قوه مع روسيا وخاصه مع
معلومات عن استعداد روسي لهجوم كبير في
همم بعد همم اسابيع اي بعد فصل الشتاء ومن
هنا القرار الغربي همم اسقاط هذا المحظور
ان صح التعبير لكن بقيت حتى قبل ايام في
اطار المدرعات الدفاعيه ما اعلنته
بريطانيا اليوم يشكل نوعيه لاول مره تسلم
او يعلن عن تسليم دبابات قتاليه
بالنسبه للبريطانيا لاوكرانيا من هذا
النوع طبعا هناك همم القراءه الغربيه التي
تغير الموقف واحداث هذه النقله وهناك الشق
البطالق في بريطانيا كون بريطانيا هي
المحور الصلب ان صح التعبير في الاطلسي مع
الولايات المتحده وبولندا وكيف اليوم اذا
قرانا المعطيات الاخيره في الاشهر الماضيه
الاردن دلاع الحرب وايضا بالنسبه لرئيس
وزراء البريطاني حتى لا يبدو اقل انخراطا
في دعم اوكرانيا من سلفيه مثل جونس الذي
يريد العوده بشكل اشكال الى الحكم ويلعب
على هذا الملف لكن يبقى انا العامل
الاساسي الذي دفع البريطانيين اتخاذ هذا
القرار هو ان هذه الحرب قد تطول وان
الهجمات الروسيه تستدعي دعاما همم نوعيا
لاوكرانيا للمقاومه حتى لو همم هناك
تساؤلات ان كانت تستطيع تحقيقا للتغيير
معادله العسكريه هذه الدبابات اربعه اشهر
بعد هذا القرار وهذا الاعلان يعني كل
الانظار تتجه الى المانيا يعني هل ستغير
بدنين موقفها وتزود اكياس بدبابات اليوم
بارك الان كل التساؤل هو هنا بمعنى ان
قرار بريطانيا هذه الدبابات من الناحيه
العسكريه هي مهمه لكنها قد لا تغير الكثير
نظرا لاعدادها وانها تستخدم وظائف خاص لكن
من الناحيه السياسيه عامل ضغط اضافي على
المانيا بشكل خاص الذي تمارس عليها ضغوط
من كل الحلفاء بشكل همم في الغرب وخاصه من
اوكراني وطريقه الحال والان من بريطانيا
وبولندا من اجل ان ترفع الحظر عن تسليم
دبابات اليوبار التي هي الصناعه المانيه
فائقه وهناك مخزون من هذه الدبابات الدول
الاوروبيه في فنلندا وهولندا بشكل خاص
ومستعد لتسليم هذه الدبابات اوكرانيه او
جزء منها لكن تنتظر الضوء الاخضر الالماني
المستشار الالماني شيلسي تعرض للضغوط في
هذا الاتجاه في الوقت نفسه ما زال مترددا
لاسباب تتعلق بحزبه تتعلق بالراي العام
الالماني الذي يبدو الى حد كبير متحفظ على
هذا الامر ولا يريد ان المانيا تنخرط
مباشره وتصبح في طرف مباشر مع مع روسيا او
ان يدفع قرار من هذا النوع اذا
ترافق مع اسلحه نوعيه الولايات المتحده
وغيرها هجوميه ايضا الى حشر روسيا في
الزاويه بشكل اكثر وبالتالي امكانيه ان
تلجا الى اسلحه لم تستخدمها سابقا او
مواجهه مباشره مع الدول الغربيه كل هذه
العوامل ياخذها بعد الاعتبار المستشار
الالماني لكن الضغوط ايضا تمارس كثيرا على
بما فيه من الاطلس الذي سيجتمع في المانيا
يوم الجمعه المقبل على مستوى الدول
الداعمه همم لاكرانيا في قائد الامريكيه
في همم في همم في المانيا من اجل اتخاذ
قرار ايضا بمزيد من دعم العسكري كما قال
امين عام الاطلس
يعني هل سيعلن قرار المانيا رفع الحظر عن
تزويد هذه الدبابات في هذا الاجتماع
بانتظار الى المقبله الضغوط كثيره كواك
شديده التي تمارس على المستشار الالماني
وقد يكون ايضا قرار استقاله وزيره الدفاع
الالمانيه عامل مساعد على اساس انها هي
كانت الى حد ما من المترددين بغض النظر عن
الهفوات الاخرى التي اثرت بشانها لكن فيما
يتعلق في مساله تزويد الاسلحه هجوميه
واسلحه ثقيله ايضا كانت من المترددين بهذا
الامر